Oh Jack your flu you're not a white type
or baby here a blue type herb a one oh
wait no that's me
oh that's I got Jackie thing ever was
Jack you've been playing action looks
good okay thanks Bob
Raj act let's do this hey how about that
boner podcast that we had the idea of
that is totally ours that's true what's
a great idea I think you're just not
wanting to I don't your your accent
seems to have changed
hey I've been working uh mark is my idol
and I just want to sound like him no
matter what so I've been really really
practicing getting his voice right
Oh someday great guy I totally get that
wow there was a lot more to this map
than I thought there would be is there
any good [ __ ] do their sin there's
another sky there's a castle not with
examples of pie slices I'm hungry I want
the pie I hope this room holy [ __ ]
that's creepy [ __ ] I don't know what's
going on there's a painting up here of
the creepiest and creepiest creep face
area he stares at me I'm upstairs
marking come on I'm in the room where
the pie conveyor belt starts oh I see
okay screw you guys hiding we're gonna
explode we're just gonna hang out with
the pipe in here whaling in this [ __ ] oh
so weird all right watched
hey it's father Grigori what he's creepy
as [ __ ] ban know about five guys are
following by the quarry Oh random thinks
we're not worried about yeah we're
ignoring yeah this is not hey this is a
raid board room I talk about our boner
podcast that high up D so so mark yeah
uh I mean J yeah
ahoy you butter cast idea Oh aye matey
huh I feel like cherry pie is a great
topic for boner hazard I'm getting that
suit I'm getting a toy agreement well
it's boner pie
everything has to be a boner thing well
cheer these burners go with cherry pies
cuz cherry pies are for China oh yeah
you've been so horny dude Matt subtitle
me laughing in Irish daga duncan a lot
III have to play video games and so on
that I forget what I'm doing and now I'm
sorry
yeah well mark mark yes okay
oh god actually Shabab you may
to schedule a play the game we're
playing again we're planar that was
exactly the strategy we were sick of
your [ __ ] that would have oh my god
there's a [ __ ] back there's an
outside backside ow God Jesus Christ
passing okay oh man I'm never gonna find
you Jam yeah now we're gonna find you
you're already with me remember
yeah right oh yeah find more idea Markus
writing works really good at this game
Maurice not here right now man I don't
know where he marked I'm here mrs.
Torrance see but whatever you say that
you didn't think I'd be clever yeah
that's absolutely exactly what he's
saying meaning about our pies being too
tough to slice okay I know where that is
oh jeez oh god what the hell is a
Gorbachev up there looking at me that's
father good gory glory gory
you give him a Gorbachev head no he's
ain't on him because I shot him exactly
where you are yeah hey [ __ ] kill the
two of you has an idea do you
I didn't do a celebrity ergo where I was
born body okay over here down I'm down
to clown get one of these huh yeah one
of these okay the right side okay all
right and then dude like this see what
I'm going for oh I see what you're going
for
yeah see what I'm playing is she getting
what for the thing I see which playing
it okay the thing tank oh yeah I mean
yeah I got it whoop well uh Bob Bob I
just needed to stop to have a mid hide
seizure and
I'll be done in a second or about me
what's happening no this is entirely my
fault and I'm very sorry no no guys I
apologize for what I've done and it's
chill don't worry we're cool
we're cool they'll never suspect up okay
okay good girl bye still Oh ooh
you can't matter you can too man wait
let me just rub my box I mean okay yeah
interpret that in the dirty way not the
explicit way need to rub your car yes
let's go okay it's still awkward but
less so yeah it was dirty already and
then you're like Cox hey Clark we did it
we did it yeah hey wait where are you oh
you're really I'm a pro don't worry
about me all right think they might be
up on top of this [ __ ] uh-huh I was
looking at it going back yeah I yell if
we pull that off we were just standing
on the open for like a full minute yeah
just rag on a random revenue ox yeah
ramen is the boner podcast so Bob the
boner kappa thats why i stalled boner
cab I know as a story I like I like the
boner podcast better sometimes joke that
these are not taking damage for some
reason someone's very I'm not someone
very angry at something yeah Jeff is
upon us feel like you feel scared scary
[ __ ] what he gets here mmm what hype
what what did he write some scary [ __ ]
when you get here oh they're already
yellow I heard the shooting and the
screaming yeah like that I'm surprised
well of course you heard the screaming
from all the way across the map I heard
you're screaming tag I don't know where
you are I thought you were
ah wait how about the replies on the
conveyor belt little there's a cafeteria
yep
Oh Bob your plan is really good right
yeah that doesn't make any sense
um I regret this notion you're clear you
can still they're not coming you're good
oh I don't fit oh no it doesn't fit
Bob do you need me my help oh you need
me help Bob okay I appreciate your offer
I'm coming to help anyway cuz omma
helpful hey Bob where'd you go yes it
goes outside I thought that we're open
to air border there Bob oh my god the
same world you were here we're so smelly
not you feel our the stealthiest Elfi
honestly Jack I have no idea oh it's
just sitting there Bobby I know I was
down this one Bob I hate you guys so
much you're riddled with bullet holes in
Solaris
oh there's 30 seconds left
oh no you guys are in trouble how we're
so good at what we do all right I'm
still a box yeah have fun I'm not a box
I might be about you never know if
you're anything but a box I give in my
gosh big boxy babe I'm coming we go Bob
I lost you oh there you are Bob I'll
save you oh no shield you is my bond
for help I show you so much big I can't
believe that worked yeah you were so
close to killing us yet Oh mammy you you
guys were that yeah we pulled it off for
sofa like 30 women were right you were
right tack is that any consolation I
working no I was right mmm hey I never
lied to you yeah I just didn't say
anything while you were murdering me and
then you gave up you should have stuck
to your you should have stuck to your
guns Jack just talk to your guns true
hey why's my guns didn't work that was
the problem
oh my god I'll check the cafeteria I
sense a disturbance in the here in the
cafeteria for ya the servants in the
food that would have been clever if I'd
said it but I didn't so good job hey
well you did say cuz I'm you remember
that's right that's right
ah yeah potations don't matter
so I'm a genie exactly not enough
editing in the world whoa there's
there's like a produce section I know
you like melons and bananas ah yeah
don't worry about it though okay do I'm
not worrying
why are you on a different kind of pie
hmm alright an Irish Irishman the pies
look different in there that way you
call yourself I'm I'm the alcoholic pie
I'm the waiting war did you in the
office upstairs oh right someone just I
did not store I did not believe it or
not go up oh god I might I love that
don't go in there there's Teletubbies
there's there's Tubby's so thank you for
favors himself and then he gets shot
instantly all right was it he just
happened it for instant you just have to
pick a room that he knows that I've been
in and out of so I am aware of the
obvious differences that he makes by
existing in there I'm just hoping you'd
leave you know Kay yeah I don't I don't
know if an ounce in here but like one of
the tables was moved but I don't know if
that's how it was so I'm not sure until
tomorrow chickens you move that table
jack is a milk drug he's a milk truck no
I did I did that I did that Dory that
okay something has happened to the milk
I'm a check outside oops
I heard they sound delicious you know
with a badger it was pie or die shut up
shut up with
I'm not angry I'm just I'm just testing
my theories I've got some theories and I
want to see how they work out by
shooting random [ __ ] yeah well my theory
of murdering people so yeah that's sort
of a new course out it no of you killed
me so stop sucking now what were you
that's harsh he was just I sit on the
conference table where there didn't used
to be a pie there's a pie in the
conference table yeah but he was the
second pie on the conference table oh
not good with you I know I know
he's height the other pie eat it I had
an idea by that time to execute it
because I looked at they were already
released I just I just want all with
these case wait for it
I messed up hands too I messed up
everything all right I found some cans
that wouldn't fall over but they fell
okay okay I give you guys a hint at a
minute huh okay okay can I open ice or
pink though it's a minute oh what's the
square root of pi ah I like something to
do with a circle or something
it's like 1.7 no two point I'm just
saying I'm a PI okay yeah at one point
one point eight three some I don't know
some close yes I'm one point eight three
hey come on man now is time for a cake
you should get better clues marvelous
time for cake now it's time for that
doesn't make any sense mark come on not
the one in one of the rooms mark stop
being so stupid I'm where Bob with
shooting things really work talking oh
really he was a magician oh I was in the
kitchen with Dinah Oh tonight oh I don't
think you're in the kitchen where I'm
just gonna say that wait am I in the
kitchen you are that's like you died
over the counter wouldn't work twice so
it does not say now it's time for cake
anywhere in this [ __ ]
hmm oh yes Bob in the kitchen tomorrow
in the kitchen Jill oh I think I know
I know where he is I think I might know
huh something looks a little out of
place
haha not in the kitchen I'm literally
done jack write this off I bite your
feet huh he's bluffing he's no no he's
not bluffing he's not bluffing me I was
a PI the entire time he was shooting oh
my god hey you were a PI on a shelf I
was close
yeah you were you were shooting the
shelf next to me I thought they seemed
weird but I couldn't I couldn't kill any
of them
yeah cuz there's an odd amount of them
oh yeah one was Jack good that's why you
came oh oh oh oh oh oh my Oh mark our
new profile oh my god I've I've made a
mistake
I've made a mistake I did my exit
professional Bob's a genius last time
this doesn't make any sense this is so
cool this is so cool this is so cool oh
god oh god I'm not as cool as Mark oh
god it's just in general your neighbor
it's so cool I feed a pie on the
conveyor belt
so cool it's so cool well what is so
cool this guy wish I could see I'm sure
I well soon when I get totally murdered
cuz I'm an idiot
Oh Castle and cool this so cool hi
there's no way mark spot is this cause
he said yes nailed it I'm on the floor
you know jockeys uh-oh
Jack's impressed by us a little things
air ha ha no one no one call me out on
that
hey Jack try yeah this is what the hell
uh someone No
Oh Marv who you are a PI and I know this
one how'd you know that
so mark I shouldn't be mice run this was
a fire whoo right Bobby you just look
like someone whose horror
depressed and trying to get away from
the rest of the workforce I'll fix it
here there we go now watch I don't want
to hang out with people no no it's ok
it's ok ok hey talk him down
talk him down oh hey wait wait I do it
no dude no I'm gonna jump I'm gonna do I
don't want to talk about this it was it
was already on the conveyor belt Ian it
was so cool
sous-sous cool accent has changed every
time you use was so cool
so I don't know that is Simon's mouth or
was it and me it was so cool yeah Jackie
find a good spot I hope so I'm not sure
what I can't really see anything someone
might be a can cuz cans got disturbed
you said that last thing about a table
yeah but uh I was in the right area my
nose does not betray me I go through and
disturb everything before I pick a
problem that's probably not a bad
strategy
yeah probably isn't and thanks for
giving it away now ho mm-hmm for the
next round list I don't know everything
will be disturbed so we'll make a
difference hmm that's totally true you
should definitely do that gun very quiet
I'm concentrating yeah nice try wait
he was a box in the room full of big
boxes and when I pushed him he was all
oh oh you sleepy
I move oh it was close
I for a second mom I was like okay move
I I was waiting to do that with the pies
if you got near me but you were shooting
he'll shoot you right oh yeah oh yeah
Bob guns record like this wait maybe
that says something about how good you
are again like that was a good place
that was on a bad spot I just always
checked I always check the easily
movable thing
because that's the first thing that I
think of when I'm playing I'm all no
well if I'm just something really
immense Bobby you're stupid
yeah I suppose oh yeah I seemed better I
get guy that I going the big I get
yelled out I don't even works by now
so the yelling thing is pretty 16 to
recording session now you get it uh why
are this again is it weird that I see
the shelves of bananas all I think of is
mark why yeah that's way cuz my god not
anymore
what is it now is it a video I know I
might be a vagina no it's uh
okay what closer doesn't have a talk
white house you Pig oh god damn it
ah Bob I got stuck what are you I'm
healing your recoverable place oh yeah I
don't think I can even kill myself where
are you Bob
let me come help Bob you know where the
boxes are where we hid our boxes first
yeah there's a little hole and I fell I
want to save my er
despite all my rage I'm still just an
orgy to gauge Jack's gonna come save you
man are you are you can't crouch and go
under the box can i I can oh I can't
shut up Jack Dean boost Dee Dee oh
there's oh there's been a path out of
the hole sweetums
baby Winx let's save that for later